[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
opening statements are presented in the
long anticipated case of the pike county
massacre as george wagner iv stands
trial for murder these murders should
have never happened
it was the result of a series of
misguided decisions
by the defendant and his family george
knew his family had done a lot of bad
things in their life but he had never
known of them to ever commit a crime of
violence and the memphis man accused of
murdering eliza fletcher faces new
charges in a separate kidnapper plus
closing arguments are presented in the
chicago federal trial of r b singer r
kelly will he face additional prison
time and later he still had difficulties
considerable difficulties being able to
manage multiple things at the same time
a closer look at the psyche of the
parkland school shooter law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer more than
six years after eight members of the
rhoden and gilley families were murdered
many as they slept the first trial
begins in pike county ohio george wagner
iv faces 22 charges including aggravated
murder law and crime's angel levy is in
pike county with what the jury has been
told
lawyers for george wagner iv say he is
innocent because he didn't actually pull
the trigger on a gun that killed anybody
that night back in april of 2016. but
prosecutors say that george wagner is
just as guilty as his brother jake and
father billy because he was there that
night and helped plan the murders
the three of them in the
late
late hours of april 21st of 2016 into
the early morning hours of april 22nd of
2016
went up to union hill road
to three different locations
that you all saw
and one location out on left fork road
and murdered
eight people who did not deserve to die
special prosecutor angie canepa told the
jury that hannah mae rhoden was the
wagner's main target that night because
she wouldn't give up custody of the
daughter she shared with jake wagner
others died simply for being there or
for what they knew canuppas said the
plan was set in motion in december 2015
when angela wagner read a facebook
message between hannah may and george
wagner's ex-mother-in-law in which she
wrote they'll have to kill me first when
discussing giving up her daughter
the night of the murders prosecutors say
jake wagner watched a scene from
boondock saints 2 a movie about two
brothers who have an assassin as a
father and the brothers are vigilantes
prosecutors say jake and george dyed
their hair the week of the murder to
look like the brothers in the movie
norman reedus is in that film and in the
show the walking dead canepas said jake
wagner felt he resembled reedus she also
displayed a screen grab from the walking
dead that shows a character using a gun
with a silencer prosecutors said the
wagners made homemade silencers using
maglite flashlights and that they
recovered photos of jake wagner holding
a colt 1911 one of the murder weapons
prosecutors say george wagner talked
about this on wiretaps
you will hear george telling jake that
he should have gotten rid of the laptop
that was confiscated in montana he will
hear him telling jake that he should
have smashed his phone rather than give
it up to bci
um you will hear george telling jake
that his honesty
has gotten them into trouble their
entire lives that jake is too honest
um you will hear george mocking god
jake wagner will testify against his
brother at this trial and we learned
when he pleaded guilty back in 2021 that
one of the reasons he did so was because
he felt remorse after finding god for
law and crime daily i'm angenette levy
in waverly ohio
thanks anjanet in the defense's opening
statement wagner's attorney said he had
no part in the murders arguing he
learned of the massacre through a phone
call instead the defense pointed the
finger at wagner's brother and
jake and mother angela
jake will tell you
george shot no one
most importantly there is no reliable
evidence that
george planned these murders
there's no independent reliable evidence
that george prepared for these murders
and there's certainly no reliable
evidence that george shot anyone
that second thing i wanted to talk to
you about is
jake and angela
who are con artists and liars
we've already touched on it some but
angela is the con artist through and
through
joining us today is la deputy public
defender phillip duvet and co-host terry
austin kind of heard that no independent
reliable testimony kind of made my ears
perk up but philip what's the defensive
strategy in what looks like a strong
case of the prosecution
well so far it sounds like they do not
have any evidence that he in fact aided
and abandoned abetted or was otherwise
an accessory if you will before the
homicide or to the homicide at most what
you have is an accessory after the fact
and even then i think the evidence is
pretty flimsy mere presence perhaps at a
crime scene or even knowledge of a crime
or even in action towards stopping a
crime is not criminal in it of itself
unless you perform some type of overt
act and furtherance of this joint
enterprise's joint conspiracy then
you're just an innocent third party and
i think it's a reach to suggest that
george wagner the fourth is you know
like a gotti a gambino a corleone or a
soprano i think it's over filed all
right we'll see how the prosecution puts
us together but terry very very long and
maybe a little dry but how was the
prosecution's opening and what should we
expect in this trial
well brian welcome back um she did a
decent job but i do agree with you she
was along and she was dry it's a lot of
information and of course she wants to
get all of that before the jury one of
the things i think was missing in that
opening statement was a demonstrative
aid i've said this before when you have
a complicated case you have to lay it
out for the jury there were not only
eight members of you know the rodent and
gilly family that were killed but they
have relatives and of course we know
that the wagners have relatives so i
definitely think that having a chart
beyond just those people who were
involved the four and the eight it would
have made sense and the jury wouldn't
have to be figuring out how to follow
along they even asked if they could have
a pad to take notes so you know it's
complicated yeah let's hope they at
least get that for the closing arguments
could be a lot of moving pieces people
decedents defendants it's going to be
interesting to see how this plays out
well
in connecticut a jury has been selected
and attorneys are preparing to present
opening statements in the second
defamation trial against infowars host
and conspiracy theorist alex jones
eight families and a first responder are
suing jones over comments he made to his
audience following the 2012 sandy hook
massacre in which a 20 year old gunman
shot and killed 26 and seven-year-olds
and six staff members of sandy hook
elementary school after the incident
jones told his audience the shooting was
a hoax telling his web show audience
that everyone involved was a crisis
actor and that it was a ploy to push gun
control efforts he has since said he
believes the massacre was real but that
his comments are protected by free
speech the eight families and fbi agents
suing jones claim they've endured death
threats and abusive comments on social
media and that jones's comments cause
emotional and psychological harm jones
was deemed liable in the three cases
against him the first of which ended in
a more than 45 million dollar payout to
plaintiffs in texas a jury of six will
determine how much joan pays in this
case the trial is expected to last four
weeks opening statements are set for
tuesday
switching now to wisconsin where the man
prosecutors say is behind the deadly
waukesha parade crash switches his plea
at a brief court appearance on friday
brooks withdrew his insanity plea
changing his plea to not guilty this
comes just weeks before brooks's trial
is set to begin on october 3rd long
crime daily first brought you the story
last november when officials say brooks
crashed his vehicle into the annual
holiday parade in waukesha wisconsin
they say brooks did not stop driving
when he hit people or barriers six
people were killed and dozens more
injured he now faces dozens of charges
including six charges of first degree
intentional homicide jurors for the
trial will be chosen from a pool of more
than 300 people if convicted brooks
could be sentenced to life in prison
brooks is due back in court on september
19th for a status hearing
still ahead on law and crime daily
closing arguments are presented in the
federal trial of disgraced singer r
kelly but first just days after he's
arrested for the abduction and murder of
eliza fletcher cleopa absent faces
additional charges for a separate rape
and kidnapping
welcome back the man prosecutors say is
responsible for the abduction and murder
of eliza fletcher is back in court for
separate kidnapping and rape charges
earlier this month thirty-eight-year-old
cleopa absent also known as cleotha
henderson was arrested and charged with
fletcher's kidnapping and murder
fletcher a memphis heiress teacher and
mother went missing while out for a jog
investigators later arrested absent
saying he forced fletcher into his suv
and later killed her right now he's
being held without bond in connection to
her death days after fletcher's body was
discovered absent was charged in a
separate kidnapping and rape incident
dating back to september 2021 at the
time on a sexual assault kit was
submitted to the tennessee bureau of
investigation but results didn't come
back right away
the combined dna index system known as
codis returned result for the 2021
incident on september 5th of this year
within hours of memphis police
recovering fletcher's body for this
crime absent was indicted on charges of
aggravated rape as well as aggravated
kidnapping and a gun charge
all right phillip with two cases being
so similar a kidnapping and a rape as
well as a kidnapping and a murder can
the prosecution use evidence of one case
in another to prove he did both
oh sure in most jurisdictions uh they
have a separate statute in their
evidence code that allows for the
introduction of evidence to prove
something other than the character of
the defendant so for example it might be
offered to prove intent
knowledge uh presence uh absence of a
motive etc so yes if he in fact is
engaged in an uncharged act that is
similar in nature to the current charge
it is absolutely admissible it's always
subject to an analysis of it being
unduly prejudicial and the court can
exclude it on those grounds again there
has to be probative value that is not
substantially outweighed by the
prejudicial effect and only a judge can
rule on that absolutely no terry we've
talked about this before we're a little
shocked about the dna results but how
were they able to connect abstinent to
the 2021 rape case so quickly
well you know it's interesting because
in this case they were able to determine
that it was his dna in you know days but
in that earlier case it took over a year
to really make that connection and one
of the things that the tennessee bureau
of investigation said was that in this
case it was a rush to get that dna and
in the prior case there was no rush so
it normally takes 33 to 49 weeks to come
back with a positive dna but i hope that
philip is right and they can use that
prior case even though there's no
guarantee it would have stopped this
case obviously that case there was no
murder this case there was i do hope
they can make that connection i do hope
the judge finds that it's more probative
and that it will definitely determine
what his motive might have been what his
intent what the scheme was because
somehow we really do need to use that
prior case to help us absolutely well
coming up on law and crime daily after a
week-long break in the trial the parking
school shooter penalty phase is back in
session plus closing arguments are
presented in the sex crimes trial of
singer r kelly what arguments both sides
make as the singer stands trial in
federal court
[Music]
welcome back attorneys present closing
arguments in the federal trial of r b
singer r kelly as he faces charges
relating to trial fixing child
pornography and sex crimes allegations
of kelly's misconduct dates back to the
early 1990s kelly and his co-defendant
and former business manager daryl
mcdavid are charged with fixing kelly's
child pornography trial in 2008 in which
kelly was acquitted he allegedly
threatened witnesses and concealed video
evidence including an alleged sex tape
with a then 14 year old girl who did not
testify in 2008 but took the stand in
this trial admitting she was the one in
the video she told the jury kelly
sexually abused her over a hundred times
in total four of kelly's accusers took
the stand jurors also heard from only
one of the defendants as mcdavid spent
the final three days of the defense's
case testifying on his own behalf after
a week of defense witnesses prosecutors
told the judge friday they needed time
to prepare a rebuttal case but he ruled
the case would go straight to closings
instead
kelly was already sentenced to 30 years
in prison in june following a separate
federal trial on racketeering and sex
trafficking charges in new york he now
faces additional prison time
phil do you think the defense did
anything to sway the jury in terms of
the credibility of the alleged victims
because at the end of the day isn't the
isn't that the only defense here
yes of course it is and a lot of it's
just going to depend on the makeup of
this jury
they're going to be judging and really
really looking at the credibility of the
name victims in this case to see if
they're just sour grapes disgruntled
malcolm tents i mean let's face it
especially back in those days in the
early 90s when r kelly was at the top of
his game he had every groupie every
young person hanging on and following
him and hoping to get a break in show
business or at a minimum becoming a
highly paid model and it was it became
in in in the end the land of broken
dreams for many of these people and now
they get their moment in time to try to
take him down so we'll see though if it
carries the day
they will have a lot to respond to
regarding the late reporting because
remember uh the girls that testified are
now in their late 30s and they were in
their early to late teens at the time of
these events yeah it's been interesting
for the defense i'm trying to turn that
in there
terry jurors heard hours of closing
arguments do you think that's overkill
and what do you expect the verdict to be
you know what brian when you have a very
long trial i think doing a closing
that's over seven hours is definitely
overkill you know i do expect a guilty
verdict here there is a ton of evidence
and i know the prosecution wants to go
over that so does the defense but look
you gotta at the end of the day weigh
how much you want to get in against
holding that jury and making sure
they're still engaged and they're
listening to what you're saying the last
thing you want to do is lose them when
you're doing your closing argument so i
do think that they're going to have to
tailor it back a bit they're going to
have to streamline and again maybe use
some evidence like the videos again to
really bring it home to the jury yeah if
your closing argument means a snack
break i think it might be too long but
we'll see how this case continues when
we come back the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial we head to florida
where defense attorneys narrowed in on
the gunman's rocky childhood
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial is back in session after a
week-long break on february 14th of 2018
a then 19 year old gunman opened fire at
marjory stoneman douglas high school in
parkland florida 17 people were killed
and 17 were injured in october of last
year the gunman pled guilty to all
charges it's now up to a broward county
jury to determine whether the defendant
will receive life in prison or the death
penalty the trial resumed for day 22 on
monday as defense attorneys continued to
make a case for the defendant's troubled
childhood for its first witness of the
week the defense called a clinical
psychologist to testify he described
what issues a defendant had when he
observed him for a neuropsychological
test
this trails b is a task of
having to quickly shift the focus of
your attention
um and he demonstrated significant
troubles being able to adjust his his
focus
um this next group of tests had to do
with uh a plot a a problem-solving task
that was relatively well uh um described
to him the instructions were given
pretty uh concretely
and all he had to do was just solve the
problem and overall did fairly well but
he demonstrated a lot of rule violations
where he would not follow the rules that
were given to him
again that was in the
mildly to moderately impaired range
on a task of
working memory this is where a person
has to do multiple things at the same
time keep track of multiple things
um he was demonstrating considerable
impairments
uh
especially when he didn't have a lot of
time to kind of get accustomed to
doing multiple things
when he had time to get accustomed to it
so this is a this is when he's doing two
things at once for a short period of
time this is for an intermediate period
of time and this is for a long period of
time
when you had him do it for a long period
of time he was doing a little bit better
but it was still
mildly to moderately impaired he still
had difficulties considerable
difficulties being able to
manage multiple things at the same time
so philip this was kind of the lion's
share of the testimony today
psychological testing do you feel as if
the defense presented any strong
evidence uh that the shooter shouldn't
get the death penalty
oh yes yes yes yes the first thing that
he said that was really key in terms of
mitigation is that he was moderately
impaired and when we talk about
impairment we're not talking about
because of the effects of having you
know
had alcohol or a few drugs it's because
of brain damage uh caused by genetic
defects and likely the introduction of
intoxicants to the mother during
gestation and as a result this caused a
childhood uh abnormalities in the brain
for this child during the formative
years and as a result it probably made
him impetuous it affected his executive
functioning his cognitive functioning uh
and everything just seemed to go haywire
where he just could not control his
impulses and if he could there was
really no way for him to regulate or
navigate it on his own
so i was going to ask whether or not
this is a strong witness i'm getting the
sense that you do think that so i'll ask
the question this way how does the
defense then build upon this witness
when there's so much evidence that the
prosecution has in pushing towards the
death penalty
what i would do next i would absolutely
bring in officials from the florida
state department of corrections the
actual prison itself who work with the
inmates at the clinical level such as
doctors nurses social workers testers
etc to explain to the jury that they
have all the resources and that they are
equipped to deal with inmates uh like
nicholas cruz and that there is no need
to execute him and that because he will
be gone
for life without parole they can handle
it they can deal with it without having
to condemn him to death well thank you
phillip and thank you terry if we have
to leave a few moments early gl great to
be back well thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you